sie wissen wurde ich in den
morgenstunden des 30
april 2017 in der wohnung in istanbul
durch eine razzia festgenommen während
dieser razzia war ich alleine mit meinem
zweieinhalbjährigen sohn damals in der
wohnung um halb fünf uhr morgens wurde
meine wohnung gestürmt von
sondereinsatzkräften maskiert schwer
bewaffnet zu dem zeitpunkt war mein mann
bereits drei wochen inhaftiert und war
im hochsicherheits gefängnis in silivri
trotz dessen dass sie das wussten sind
die sehr gewaltsam in meine wohnung
einmarschiert haben mich zu boden
gedrückt haben sie auf mich drauf also
mit dem knie draufgesetzt
mein sohn war im zimmer hat geschlafen
wurde durch einen bewaffneten maskierten
polizei kraft sozusagen direkt mit der
waffe auf ihn drauf gerichtet aufgeweckt
danach wurde meine wohnung dreieinhalb
stunden was von diesen maskierten
menschen durchsucht zu während dieser
dreieinhalb stunden war ich jeglicher
repression und bedrohung ausgesetzt
ich wurde eigentlich die ganze zeit über
beschimpft und bedroht obwohl diese
menschen nicht nicht kannten sie hat nur
das befehl ein befehl bekommen mich
festzunehmen
ich bin zwar heute hier aber hunderte
kollegen kolleginnen oppositionelle
anwälte studenten 70.000 studenten sind
inhaftiert sind immer noch nicht frei
deswegen ist es nicht so dass ich mich
wirklich über die ausreise freue weil
ich weiß dass ich in dem land in dem ich
eingesperrt war nichts verändert hat
ich denke nicht daran
ich denke nicht dass sich im land in
richtung demokratisierung etwas
verändert hat